évidemment il ya des dangers en france
ya des gens qui sont exposés à des
agressions dans la rue ça m'est déjà
arrivé donc je ne peux pas le nier le
fait que en marchant dans une rue
parisienne on peut être attaquée se
faire voler son portable ce quelque
chose que j'ai personnellement
expérimenté pour autant je pense que
l'expérience personnelle ne vaut pas
pour expliquer une situation
structurelle ce que je crois c'est que
effectivement la violence elle est plus
visible aujourd'hui parce qu'on a de
meilleur moyen pour la documenter quand
on est jeune aujourd'hui contrairement à
quand on était jeunes dans la génération
on est en permanence exposés à des
vidéos de violence ou sont victimes de
violence des gens qui permet de recevoir
et c'est vrai que si on est toute la
journée sur les réseaux sociaux où on
voit des gens mettre en scène aussi des
fêtes des scènes de violence des gens
qui nous sont proches on est aussi
exposée à de nouvelles formes de
harcèlement je comprends qu'on se
sentent davantage en danger que l'on
pouvait sentir en danger il ya dix vingt
ou trente ans parce que cette sensation
de danger elle est amplifiée par le fait
qu'on la voit et on peut effectivement
assisté à des agressions de gens qu'on
connaît après quand on est jeune
d'ailleurs je remercie monsieur de venir
témoigner de son agression parce que je
sais que c'est douloureux et c'est
encore plus douloureux de l'exposer
devant des centaines de milliers de
personnes donc je vous remercie des
millionnaires se recueille à celle où
des millions de personnes c'est vrai que
c'est toujours celle annoncée ou des
personnes qui tu nous regardes avec avec
attention donc je vous remercie et
encore une fois je sais que c'est
toujours compliqué de d'entendre des
gens débattre canton avec une situation
et mon intention c'est vraiment pas de
vous blesser de vous aux français et de
nier ce que vous avez vécu parce que
voilà je respecte vraiment votre votre
sentiment et votre votre expérience
maintenance quand on regarde les
chiffres sont ceux dont on s'aperçoit
c'est que aujourd'hui 50% des violences
jesi sont des violences intrafamiliales
la vérité c'est que dans la vie quand on
vit en france on a plus de risques
d'être agressés par une personne qu'on
connaît que par une personne qu'on ne
connaît pas quand on est une femme on a
plus de risques d'être tué par son
conjoint que d'être tuée dans un par un
inconnu au coin d'une rue la vérité de
la violence en fait en france que ce
qu'il s'agisse des crimes sexuels des
violences sexuelles ou des violences
physiques qu'on soit un enfant qu'on
soit un adulte elles surviennent
davantage de la part des personnes qu'on
connaît et je pense que on fantasme
beaucoup l'agression
en la faisant porter à un sombre inconnu
dans un parti
regarder l'actualité et la séparation
non mais je vous ai parlé donc je ne
vous je ne mets à l'emporter s'il vous
plaît man show
passe sa vie sur son fauteuil à regarder
la
télé réalité c'est ce que les généraux
n'y a
aucun cas terminé je dis moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas de faire le show en
criant à tout va des quelqu'un oserait
ce qui m'intéresse c'est effectivement
de dire ce qui se passe en réalité donc
évidemment on peut prendre le risque
d'être agressé dans la rue ça existe
mais la réalité de la violence je pense
en tout cas d'une grande partie de la
violence qui existe c'est la violence
des personnes qui sont des personnes
identifiées et cette violence là il faut
aussi il faut aussi la neutraliser je
pense que c'est important de rappeler
cela juliette jusqu'au bout lui
intervenu il ya quelque chose qui est
important aussi qu'on n'a pas encore
abordé
mettons que vos chiffres soit vrai ce
qui n'est pas du tout le cas il ya aussi
la même ce changement dans la nature
s'ils sont des crimes et des agressions
et ça c'est important d'en parler est ce
qu'avant il ya 35 ans temps voyait comme
ça j'ai pris l'exemple du chauffeur de
bus mais je peux aussi parler de de
l'ancien parachutiste emmanuel cueff qui
est mort cette semaine rouée de coups
devant sa femme qui est mort en sortant
d'un restaurant dans d'atroces
conditions est ce qu'on voyait ça il ya
35 ans temps des gens se faire lyncher
gratuitement comme sa marine pour un sac
à main alors pour avoir c'est ça que je
me avant avant j'ai besoin qu'ils
avaient quand même il y avait de la
violence a toujours eu de la violence
mais y avait un motif une sorte de
mobiles quelque chose là c'est la pure
haine c'est de la haine et ça ça ça on
ne voit pas dans les chiffres peut-être
que si des dégâts des chips europe
maintenant il ya mille agressions par
jour il ya 35 ans temps avant vous aviez
l'impression vous avez quel âge excusez
moi